hello everybody its it is my pleasure to
announce that once again the match is
returning capital ones the match
champions for charity it's going to be
May 24th that's a Sunday afternoon three
o'clock Eastern time is when it hits the
air on TNT TBS truTV and HLN I'm Ernie
Johnson and I am pleased to be joined by
the four competitors who you will see in
the match champions for charity
Phil Mickelson who won the match head to
head over Tiger Woods in 2018 this year
there will be there will be partners
Phil will partner with Tom Brady Tiger
will be paired up with Peyton Manning as
we like to call it four icons one place
one time that's pretty catchy isn't it
guys maybe it's not as catchy as I was
led to believe we have a lot to talk
about about the golf course and about
the pairings but the first thing I want
to to talk about is something I saw
online the other day Instagram from Tom
Brady and this had to do this is before
I guys this has even been announced that
this is going to happen and I don't know
if you guys have all seen this but there
we go
never had much of a hard time beating
the Colts or a tiger don't see this time
being much different and I and I really
do like the wardrobe that you have a
selected Tom for tiger and for Peyton
looked like a little Hot Wheels t-shirt
on dad Peyton and in the so what's
getting so it's starting early this year
is it not Tom what gave you the
inspiration for that
but I just want to have a little fun I
actually thought I was gonna be Tiger
partner but then I Peyton's dad called
and and switched the team so I decided
to get together and see if we could we
could take them on so I'm excited I'm
excited to get out there my golf isn't
quite with it it probably was at one
point but I got a good partner and uh
you know we got some great competition
so it should be a lot of fun you know
that that partner of yours Phil you have
you win the award for taking the time to
set up your shot because there's a lot
of hardware in there there's a there's a
photograph there's a belt can you take
me through everything that's in the
picture tigers pretty familiar with this
obviously when you were putting the
jacket on it fit perfect thank you and
then this is the trophy for the match I
don't know actually tell you if you know
what this looks like you might have
caught a glimpse but that's that's
actually what the trophy looks like had
you would have won I just got an ice
bath how did this all come about first
the memories tiger and Phil that you
have of the the first time we did this a
couple years ago what was your biggest
takeaway on that and and what did you
think at that point
hey if we do this again let's try this
one I was crazy that we're doing in
Vegas under the lights we've had a
little moment where it was getting a
little dark and we didn't have enough
light at the time I was one down I
chipped in on seventeen to make a little
more interesting and then we play a part
three from the clubhouse a few times
morning so obviously Ernie the thing I
came away with the last match was you
know
nine million dollars that was that was
nice and as well as this little trophy
but the thing is Ernie early Tigers got
the best of me throughout our careers I
mean if you look at the big picture the
guy's got the greatest record in the
history of the game so any little thing
that I have I'll hold on to and this win
I'll hold on to that and I know that it
bothered him you know why I know it
bothered him because he insisted that we
come back and compete the next one at
his home course so that he had the home
course advantage I totally understand
that line of thinking I probably would
have done the same thing if I had lost
and was pissed off too but Tom and I are
going to go down to your home course and
you're going to defend our title again
and then there will be no excuses this
will be yes medalist golf club and hope
sound and uh a place where Tiger they
have a handful of tiger tees is
everybody gonna play the tiger tees or
just Tiger play the tiger tees and what
is that animal that's behind you right
now
border collie that month over yeah we're
all going to play for the back piece
well the two pros are they will fight
for the rough jr. eyes yeah the mental
sis is difficult obviously there's wide
fairways even Phil can hit those
fairways and bushes everywhere and he's
gonna have to partner quite a bit tell
me about your golf game Peyton I don't
know we'll see
we'll find out that weather's been a
little up and down here in Denver I was
telling Tom it's been snowing some here
in Denver in late April and May so you
never know what you're going to get I
played the medalist before with Tiger
from those tiger tees and old teammate
of mine Brandon Stokley was with me
remember that tiger and on the 18th hole
I leaned over to Stokely and asked if I
could borrow a ball I was out of
by the time my guys at 18 and he says oh
he said all he had was a yellow one left
I cannot play a yellow ball Tiger Woods
so we're digging like in the marsh one
more ball so I could finish the hole so
I think you saw Tom and I both shaking
our heads at the thought of those tiger
tees but it's a hard course Ernie the
course you know the tournament had to be
in Florida you know after Tom's be any
arrests couldn't the state so it had to
be in Florida Tiger and I talked to the
sheriff and Tampa he's gonna be allowed
to go to Palm Beach to play I'll be
honest I've never played Tom very well
on his home turf and so maybe this is
considered a neutral site and I would
have loved to have had this tournament
in a place where they don't like Tom
very much Indianapolis Denver Boston Oh
after he just betrayed them and broke
their heart so Palm Beach is the best we
can probably do look I think the teams
are fair I think you know Phil chose the
right partner and Tom together you know
they have 11 championships Tiger and I
have 17 the way I count it right Tiger
under 15 plus my two so it's a little
closer and the championships with tiger
and Phil being together but it's a great
cause
I know tiger and Phil did it lash
together Tom and I were glad to be on
board being a code via 19 relief
fundraiser it's gonna be some fun and
raise money for a great cause so glad
glad and honored to be a part of it it's
on me had a lot to say there how was the
state of your game somewhere between
poor and pitiful but uh you know
unfortunately I'm focusing on football
right now
and I'm still working and golf will come
at
but I can get a little bit streaky I too
played medalist once I played it last
year I took that player with Justin
Thomas and is I played 18 at MacArthur
and then I shot like a 94 and I was like
you can't get any worse and then I drove
over to medallist and shot 106 I'm gonna
bring a couple dozen golf balls and
hopefully I can you know work it around
the course I might hit some of those
little those little stingers off the tee
to try to keep it in play but it's very
volatile and you know but I got a great
partner so well hang in there as long as
we can race you
all right real quick yeah Tom with Tom
will tell you that this is going to be
one of the few times he and I got to
play against each other in golf
we certainly competed on the field but
in golf we've actually been partners a
decent amount and not a great record
right Tom I mean really the last time we
play we got beat by an 84 year old and a
77 year old like closed out on 15 I mean
yes it was it was
I've had some disappointing defeats and
a you know Tom had that meeting at all
but that was that was a tough one for
both of us so we're each picking up each
kind of upgrading in our partners this
time playing with Tiger and yeah hey
Phil as you heard Tom running down the
state of his game was your confidence
level dropping at all because he was
brutally honest about where it stands
right now yeah I saw that I think I'm
probably not going to be chirping as
much as I had anticipated but I have
confidence in Tom I've seen him play
some of his best golf when he wasn't
sharp when he wasn't expecting to play
well sometimes expectations get in the
way of performing well and so going in
here
to a foreign site on there
course without his AGame would lead
anybody to think that we you know
wouldn't have much of a chance and I
think we might even Lowell these two to
sleep a little bit
we might even let them you know win a
hole or two and get up early and try to
lull him to sleep and then finish strong
tonight you're yeah you're playing
you're playing best ball on the front
correct and and so so four balls in play
on the front but what the modified
pattern it's shot on a man right Ernie I
feel like there's a little adventure
I've been studying a lot of film and
filming a lot of Payton's rounds the
last couple weeks so I feel like I've at
least got a head start
so you know it's just part of its the
preparation and that gives you a lot of
confidence so I feel like you know in
two weeks from when we actually start
I'm gonna be prepared I know what I'm
going against and hopefully after Phil
and I win they don't go you know try to
change the rules on us or you know send
the tapes into the to the NFL I don't
know if Peyton can still do that now
that he's retired and try to change some
of the rules to make it a little easier
the next time but this this modified
this modified alternate shot that you'll
play on the back explain that to me
tiger yeah I all four must be off from
our various tees and then we select the
one that we want to fish off the hole
with we all play it from there till the
hole is completed there's a pump of
holes number 11 and 14 are are both
drivable par fours so it could be
interesting a couple good par fives and
so a lot of volatility we've had a lot
of money games that have switched hands
on those specific holes and see that
happening here yeah Phil you know do you
know how dangerous that can that
alternate shot can be and how and how it
can a swing match and you don't want to
put your partner in a in a in a less
than ideal situation
how much pressures are going to be on
Payton and Tom in this too to not put
the pros in a bad spot even in the
modified alternate shot one of us is
gonna get the ball in play hopefully and
then we just have to worry about the
iron shots the iron shots in but between
the two of us we're gonna we're gonna
get one of those balls in those big wide
fairways yeah
the other part about this whole
competition obviously the most important
part about this competition is the is is
what you're doing for charity and when
we when we look at the situation we're
all in right now
it's so surreal for anybody in any line
of work but I think for sports fans it's
you know there's the this thirst and
this and this hunger to watch live
competition is it been tiger has it been
that way for you to where it's been like
man I'd I'd give anything to watch
something that's actually happening now
and we don't know the outcome well
that's what sports is it's the ultimate
reality show you don't know what's gonna
happen I don't know the outcome you
could have underdogs beating the glass
and you can have tough type competitions
I as an athlete I missed that I know it
feels like to be in that arena I miss
watching my friends compete and I can't
wait the football season and watch watch
Tom play again
basketball season I I'm dying for my
Lakers come back and play my Dodgers
aren't aren't throwing are blaming this
is you're supposed to begin the season
now we have golfers we've been playing
lot down here a lot of guys have been
playing matches around here but it's
still not playing for trophies it's just
different and we miss competing and I
just really do I really do miss watching
my friends go out there and do it at a
high level and put whatever they have on
the line to succeed and we all do and
hopefully we all come back safe and
it'll be a new norm for sure and what
that's going to look like is gonna be
very interesting it would be without the
fans initially which is going to be very
very different at least we'll have much
work again I'd like to really hear from
all of you on that on on just what it
what it means to the sporting population
and the fans who have have been wanting
to to see something to see something
that that is new and is live in his
competitive thing well certainly nothing
to compare what's going on right now but
in dealing with Katrina you know seeing
my hometown New Orleans devastated by
Petrine by Katrina other disasters
certainly the horrible 9/11 tragedy
I think people admit that sports can be
a distraction from the tough times and
tough things going on and if watching
Tiger Woods and Phil Mickelson play golf
can take their minds off their business
struggling someone in their family whose
health is struggling then that can be a
positive and maybe that can help them
have a good attitude and maybe it helps
somebody heal along the way or give
somebody hope that hey there's something
good on the other side of this but yeah
a lot of people are hurting right now
learning a lot of people struggling you
know I mentioned New Orleans my hometown
as once again being hit hard by this by
this virus as are many communities
around the country so you know I don't
think this event would happen if it
wasn't going to benefit those people
that are hurting and so I think that's
why it's a it's a double wind to watch
only anybody wants to see Tom and I hit
golf balls as much as they want to see
these two Hall of Famers tiger and Phil
play golf and I know there's you know
McIlroy and Dustin and and are playing
in a tournament next the week before us
which would be great I'm glad
sports fantasy golf return I enjoy
watching those guys compete so for Tom
and I to go behind the ropes and watch
how Phil and Tom
excuse me watch out tiger and Phil do
their thing and to be a part of it and
to raise money we're glad to do it and
if it helps some people along the way
take their minds off of it that's even
better
yeah go ahead tom well I think certainly
the know the opportunity to do good and
I think you know for you know speaking
for for myself and the way the other
three
you know tiger and Phil and Peyton have
engaged in you know some
behind-the-scenes conversations about
you know what our opportunity to do good
is and I think that's at the core of
what I think the match was all about and
I know it wasn't like that last year and
is it played into this year you know
everybody felt like this was a moment in
time to you know use you know the
exposure that we can get for doing great
in communities that are really in need
and you know everybody has a little bit
of a chance to give to different places
that are really important to them I'm
all amongst the situation that we're
currently in but it's really a um you
know just a unique moment in time and I
think the ability to do good and help
others is at the core of what this was
all about in the fact that you know look
I get an opportunity to go play golf
with three of the guys that I've always
looked up to in sports I something I
certainly you know couldn't turn down so
hopefully the fans will enjoy it I know
they will I think we're gonna have a lot
of fun there's been a little trash talk
you know as you've seen a little behind
the scenes I'm sure there'll be a lot
more of that and I got to get out get it
out get it out all the way early because
I know once I'm on the course I'll be
probably very quiet from the stuff about
all the you know shots all beginning but
Mayweather so I went you than the Conor
McGregor approach yeah Barkley analyzed
in me and Tom's swing just
look he was there he was there the first
time they're gonna make an announcement
on the analyst but that's it's always
that always makes you feel better if
Charles is there you always know that
you're loud you're not the worst guy at
the gap you know that's right there's
always him you know that's like when I
won the black masters two years ago and
defeated defeated Charles you know it
did wonders for my for my day yeah it's
like Phil's Chargers and it's always
gonna be a team you know it's worse than
you right yeah both of you guys owned
our Chargers so so for me I want you to
realize how big of it is for me to come
out and be with you both because I have
had such hostility for so many years
still I'll give you the last word well I
have the utmost respect for these three
individuals I think Tigers the greatest
golfer that's ever played and these two
are the two best at what they do and for
these gentlemen to come together and use
their platform to help others and do it
in a fun entertaining way I just really
appreciate it and it's also in an area
that it's not your comfort zone you grew
up both Tom and Payton playing football
knock off and they're going out of their
comfort zone going on national TV to
showcase their golf game and that's
that's always a not an easy thing to do
but for them to do that and do it for
others too to create a fun entertaining
environment as well as help others I
just have a lot of respect for so so
just know that the smack talk that we
have it's all in good fun and I have
nothing but the utmost respect for these
three gentlemen guys we look forward to
it may 24th three o'clock Eastern Time
Capital One's the match champions for
charity with all the proceeds going to
covet 19 relief we want to thank the
folks at Cisco because they they helped
set this thing up and made it happen
with everybody's equipment and we got
everybody here on the same page and able
to talk about it so thanks to the folks
from Cisco and we look forward to seeing
what
transpires at medalists down there in
Hobe Sound Tigers home course in in the
match champions for charity guys thank
you so much for your time and and good
luck out there thank you thanks